[Música]
nosotros vamos con nuestro segundo
invitado del día al que le planteamos el
siguiente escenario y Es que hoy 8 de
junio se conmemora el Día Mundial de los
océanos una fecha que nos sirve para
conversar acerca de la situación de
nuestros mares que están gravemente
amenazados por la actividad humana la
ONU advierte que extraemos más de los
océanos de lo que se puede reponer y
alterar la situación en el agua
repercute en toda la vida sobre el
planeta los mares albergan una enorme
biodiversidad y a los humanos nos
alimentan o nos conectan Además de que
generan gran parte del oxígeno que
respiramos ahora Contamos con a Cristian
laborda Él es director de Mission Blue
chile experto en océanos Cristian
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 Le agradezco mucho
su participación en el programa
Hola buen día rosson placer es saludarte
de acá de la ciudad de Valparaíso se va
Puerto en el Pacífico Sur Cristian
empiezo pidiendo un breve panorama sobre
la situación de los océanos hoy en día
en comparación por ejemplo con la era
preindustrial en términos de temperatura
pero también de biodiversidad por
ejemplo
bueno Tú lo has dicho en la nota
introductoria en los comentarios en
cuanto a que hoy día Estamos celebrando
el océano La pregunta es si tenemos
mucho que celebrar hoy día en relación a
la época que tú mencionas Tenemos muchos
más información Data científica que nos
permite con certeza indicar las amenazas
que está teniendo el océano por un lado
la contaminación en sus diferentes
aspectos plásticos es muy importante el
exceso de nutrientes la sobrepesca y la
pesca ilegal Yo diría que son algunos de
las amenazas más importantes que a nivel
global está afectando al océano es decir
las amenazas provienen de la actividad
humana no y el calentamiento Digamos si
la escasez de biodiversidad son un
resultado exclusivamente de la actividad
humana Hoy hay otros factores
bueno no hay no hay duda de que eso es
la actividad humana es decir a tanto
Industrial que estamos realizando como
humanidad La que está produciendo la
alza de alzas de temperatura el impacto
importante del cambio climático producto
de eso está produciendo una afectación
importante a los ecosistemas marinos la
muerte de las grandes barreras de coral
en muchas áreas del planeta la
afectación de pérdida de especies es
decir desaparición de especies marinas
son solo un ejemplo de este gran
problema que estamos enfrentando hoy en
día y que a diferencia de las normas
internacionales no reconoce barreras
geográficas claro y precisamente para
nosotros quizás son más evidentes las
consecuencias de la crisis climática que
suceden sobre la Tierra no incendios a
sequías porque vivimos al final es sobre
Tierra Firme le pido Qué consecuencias
tiene la degradación de los ecosistemas
marinos para la para la vida humana
también
bueno la afectación se ve en la
disminución de las posibilidades que
tienen las comunidades locales que se
han desarrollado a lo largo del tiempo
en los bordes costeros ahí hay claros
ejemplos de cómo se van perdiendo esta
especie quiero mencionar por ejemplo el
relevante rol que tienen los bosques de
algas no solamente para albergar
ecosistemas por ejemplo la Patagonia
chilena que es muy importante pero
también el Sumidero de carbono que
significa es decir La regulación
climática y por lo tanto hay una
contribución muy importante que tiene
efectos no solo en este caso por ejemplo
en Chile sino que es una contribución
global para solucionar el problema de la
mitigación de los efectos del cambio
climático se trata de como las
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza como
son las áreas marinas protegidas
absorben una cantidad importante de
gases de efecto invernadero
y Cristian le pido hablar de una región
muy particular Y es que ayer salió un
informe que alertaba de que el Ártico
podría quedarse sin hielo por primera
vez en un septiembre entre 2030 y 2050
le preguntó Qué efectos tendría esta
situación para la vida en todo el
planeta bueno los estudios vienen dando
cuenta de esta situación que es
alarmante pero los últimos estudios
particularmente han indicado que
definitivamente en esta transcurso de
tiempo que usted indica simplemente el
hielo va a desaparecer del Ártico
obviamente ocurre ahí un impacto directo
en las especies que necesitan del hielo
para sobrevivir y si bien es cierto como
el Ártico es A diferencia de la
antártica no es un continente es decir
es solo una masa de agua el
derretimiento de estos hielos no
produciría un efecto de subida de mar
Pero qué duda cabe que nuevamente las
actividades humanas se van a incrementar
las rutas marítimas de comercio nuevos
caladeros de pesca las situaciones de
posibles conflictos que ahí existen y
por lo tanto también siempre el que
termina pagando la cuenta de esto es el
ambiente y es el océano y le pido para
ir cerrando Cuál es concretamente el
llamado a la acción porque la ONU en
este día dice pongamos a los a los
océanos por delante pero particularmente
que es responsabilidad y Qué acciones
deben tomar por un lado las autoridades
los gobiernos por otro lado las grandes
empresas y también la población más rica
del planeta bueno las normas
Internacionales El multilateralismo
ambiental ha tomado decisiones que
aunque he pasado en estándares mínimos
son claras para afectar todas estas
amenaza por mencionar por ejemplo Los
acuerdos sobre las nuevas metas de la
comprensión de biodiversidad para
proteger el 30% del océano y tierra al
2030 es un claro ejemplo de ello el
acuerdo de dnj para proteger la alta mar
de todas estas amenazas son ejemplos es
decir tenemos las herramientas qué es lo
que necesitamos ahora es voluntad
política de los gobiernos
transversalmente quiero decir a nivel
local a nivel regional y sobre todo a
nivel nacional para implementar estos
estándares internacionales que nos van a
permitir mitigar reducir estas amenazas
que está enfrentando el océano hoy en
día Cristian pues Lamentablemente se nos
acaba el tiempo pero muchísimas gracias
por haber compartido su conocimiento y
su análisis aquí en France 24 Gracias a
Dios un saludo nosotros hacemos una
breve pausa pero enseguida regresamos
[Música]